sources tell CBS news a relationship
between the Russia and the Trump
presidential campaign developed long
before the election federal
investigators are looking at several
campaign associates and there is new
information this morning about former
FBI director James Comey --zz efforts to
stay independent of the president Jeff
PJ's is at FBI headquarters in
Washington
Jeff good morning good morning CBS News
has learned that during the period
between Election Day and the
inauguration US intelligence officials
were concerned about information being
shared illegally with Russian operatives
for months investigators had been
tracking communications that they felt
were cause for alarm
it's a rigged system investigators are
looking into whether the Trump campaign
may have been coordinating with the
Russians as early as April 2016
sources say investigators found multiple
contacts considered a cause for concern
a former US government official tells
CBS News you could see the hallmarks
throughout including conversations
picked up by electronic intercepts the
FBI is scrutinizing former Trump
campaign Chairman Paul Manafort foreign
policy adviser Carter page and the
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn he saw his role as protecting the
FBI from the White House Benjamin
witness a friend of former FBI director
James Comey said Comey told him how the
president put him on the spot two days
after the inauguration who said he
stands in the part of the room that is
as far from Trump as it is physically
possible to be oh and there's the James
pump singles him out in a fashion that
he regarded as sort of you know
calculated he's become more famous than
me Comey was just completely disgusted
by the episode he thought it was an
intentional attempt to compromise him in
public
five days later on January 27th at a
White House dinner the president
allegedly asked Comey if he would pledge
his loyalty On February 13th
Flynn was forced to resign after
misleading vice president pence about
his contacts with the Russian ambassador
the next day President Trump spoke to Co
me alone in the Oval Office Comey wrote
a memo detailing how he says Trump
indicated he wanted him to drop the
federal investigation in recent days the
pressure has been on the former FBI
director to make those memos public and
to testify again on Capitol Hill but
some members of Congress indicating that
since the appointment of the special
counsel that may complicate efforts to
bring Comey back on Capitol Hill to
answer questions again Charlie thanks
Jeff